[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Fred bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline dans la presse
aujourd'hui on en parlait à l'instant le
mouvement de grève aujourd'hui en France
un mouvement social qui est d'abord
parti des raffineries et des pots de
carburant qui est en train de prendre de
l'ampleur mais cette journée de
mobilisation fait bien sûr la Une de
nombreux quotidiens français ce matin a
commencé par Libération leur et grève
avec ce dessin de coco montrant Emmanuel
Macron le président Macron soufflé par
les revendications des manifestants le
journal accuse le gouvernement d'avoir
sous-estimé l'ampleur du mécontentements
d'avoir géré le conflit dans les
raffineries à la hussarde avec des
réquisitions et il s'inquiète plus
largement du gouffre qui s'est creusé
selon lui entre beaucoup de salariés et
les dirigeants du pays salaire l'essence
de la grève l'humanité précise que cet
appel à la modulation a été lancée par
la CGT FO solidarité la FSU qui demande
une général des rémunérations en France
Midi Libre annonce une journée noire et
se demande si les pénuries et les grèves
notamment dans les transports risquent
de bloquer le pays dans un entretien au
journal local le secrétaire général de
la sfdt Laurent Berger n'appelle pas lui
à la grève et dit privilégiez les
discussions entreprises par entreprise
selon lui le bordel je cite ça n'a
jamais servi à personne Laurent Berger
qu'on retrouve aux côtés du patron de la
CGT Philippe Martinez dans le dessin de
CaC pour l'opinion la méthode berger dit
là c'est cheminérant ensemble la méthode
Martinet dit l'autre tout de cuir vêtue
le journal évoque les différences de
méthodes entre les deux syndicats
illustration du clivage vieux clivage
entre réformistes et contestataires sur
fond d'élection professionnelle à venir
à la Une également Hélène la décision de
l'Union européenne de sanctionner l'Iran
si la four de drones de combat à la
Russie pour la guerre en Ukraine est
avérée
étrangères européens sont prêts à
prendre des mesures concrètes contre
Téhéran qui ni la fourniture de drones à
Moscou en cas de preuve irréfutables je
cite le quotidien britannique prévient
que les allégations de soutien militaire
iranien à la Russie ainsi que les
critiques occidentales de la répression
en Iran risque de compliquer encore un
peu plus les efforts diplomatiques pour
relancer par ailleurs les discussions
sur le nucléaire iranien l'Iran Pauline
ou l'inquiétude grandit sur le sort
réservé à elnaz
récapit cette jeune athlète iranienne a
participé le week-end dernier au
championnat d'Easy d'escalade à Séoul en
Corée du Sud sans porter le voile en
signe de soutien au mouvement de
contestation depuis ses proches sont
sans nouvelles et le site indépendant
Iran wire affirme qu'il nazerait Kab a
été emmené une fois la compétition
terminée à l'ambassade d'Iran à Séoul
d'où elle pourrait être rapatrié à
Téhéran pour y être directement envoyé à
la prison des vignes de Téhéran cette
prison où sont détenus de nombreuses
opposants politiques ou un incendie a
fait au moins 10 morts c'était samedi
dernier je vous propose à présent Hélène
de nous emmener au Royaume-Uni ou le
ministre des Finances a annulé hier la
quasi-totalité des baisses d'impôts
annoncé il y a quelques jours à peine
par la première ministre liste
déchire les plans de la première
ministre dans une volte-face stupéfiante
de gardien dit que le nouveau chancelier
de l'Échiquier en effet non seulement à
nous annoncer des hausses d'impôts et
des réductions des dépenses mais qu'il
est également revenu du moins en partie
sur le gel des prix de l'énergie qui
était le mantra de listrus
prend les commandes et trust redoutent
la sortie annonce une journée très très
compliquée pour les stress de ma lors de
la séance de questions au gouvernement à
la Chambre des communes la première
ministre fantôme de Sun ironise sur le
désespoir de listrus condamné à écouter
sur son banc et en silence sont ministre
des Finances le plus déchaîné Pauline
étant le Daily Star qui monteront le
voir la patronne du gouvernement sous la
forme d'une feuille de laitue ma foi
c'est défréchie en soins intensifs en
livre supporte un jeu de mot assez
intraduisible et bien sûr les
dessinateurs de presse boivent du petit
lait nous prenons temporairement le
contrôle de la situation pour stabiliser
les choses indique le
généralissimo ministre des Finances
Jerry me Hunt un dessin de blower pour
The Guardian stabilité stabilité
répètent listrots dans ce dessin de
Brighty pour de Sun ce qui laisse
stabilisé tant ce couteau que lui a
planté dans le dos sans ministre des
Finances l'est but comme on dit list
trust mourante dans cette parodie du
tableau de Rembrandt la leçon d'anatomie
du docteur TolP alias Jérémy Hunt un
dessin de
l'excellentissimotem browland pour The
Times inspirez vous avez dit un mot pour
terminer Hélène de l'attribution du
Ballon d'Or 2022 chez les hommes aux
Français Karim Benzema et chez les
femmes à l'espagnol Alexia pouillas les
héros du jour on les honneur de la
presse sportive espagnole des
rousticiens et Oro de justice et d'or
salut Marca qui juge plus que mérité
c'est de ballon d'or de l'or pur c'est
merveilles elles-mundo Deportivo en
rappelant que Karim Benzema et le
premier Français vous l'avez dit depuis
Zinédine Zidane en 1998 a remporté cette
des créations Alexia potéia celle
obtient pour la deuxième année d'affilée
la journée la joueuse du Barça qu'on
retrouve chez elle à la Une du journal
catalan sportif sport Alexia edor un
bonne camarade aussi puisqu'elle n'a pas
manqué de saluer ses cookies coéquipiers
car une Benzema lui ramène le Ballon
d'Or à la maison et l'équipe évoque à la
fois une consécration une apothéose et
une promesse toucher son rêve d'enfant
après de 35 ans après des années
chaotiques une condamnation judiciaire
cinq années loin de l'équipe de France
et l'une des plus belles histoires et
les plus renversantes de la distinction
attribuée par France Football depuis
1956 ces merveilles le journal
effectivement merci beaucoup Hélène
c'était la revue de presse